it's Monday March 2nd so it's time for
another monthly update video in which
I'll talk about what went on in February
very short but packed month and what
we've got coming up in the month of
March
so I always like to begin by
highlighting three big things and big
thing number one that I think quite a
few of you viewers have probably seen
already is we launched the wisdom for
life
radio show last Friday ran for an hour
you can see the link to it below in the
description if you click on see more big
thing number two my wife in shaka and i
have been invited to participate in some
worldwide stoical events which is pretty
cool we got some planning going on looks
like there's going to be one in june in
london or somewhere around there and
then we've also been invited to present
at stoical on x toronto right after the
stoical con conference which will both
be going to as well so that's kind of
another fun big thing on the horizon and
then big thing number three which
affects my my video production to some
degree down the line is I have my
classes for fall at least at two of the
institutions where I regularly teach so
I'll talk a little bit about that in the
February section those are the three big
things I wanted to sort of highlight now
let's talk about what went on in
February February was a pretty packed
month as far as events and teaching and
all these other sorts of things so I
began the month with the fifth year of
the quarterly series philosophers in the
midst of history I'm talking about
Epicurus and the epicurean tradition the
video for that is below so you can watch
that if you're interested if you missed
it that's kind of a big deal
and then we continued on with another
series the month
worlds of speculative fiction series
this time concentrating on China mia
ville we had a great discussion about
about his work and straight into a lot
of topics quite a few online events I
did my usual ask me anything session I
managed to get in to philosophy pop ups
as well and the half hour Hegel you know
Q&A and discussion sessions and of
course the wisdom for life radio show so
that was kind of a big event we also had
some local meetups as well the stoic
fellowship meets monthly and I was there
for that and then we had our MKE that's
milwaukee sofia the Society of
philosophers in America meeting and and
discussed some interesting topics
they're teaching two of my classes that
had not yet begun actually began in
February one is it at Carthage College
is my business ethics class that I
started teaching there fairly regularly
the other is an online class from
Milwaukee Area Technical College which
is a 12-week version of what it would
normally be a 15 week class so it starts
a little bit later I've been carrying
out a lot of tutorial work and my usual
philosophical counseling some consulting
regularly and of course editing for
stoicism today and doing doing quite a
few of those things as well and I'm
working on some book projects with some
colleagues and an article that with
another colleague we're waiting to hear
whether the paper of that is going to be
accepted or not if it is then we got to
step up our production so that we're
ready for the conference that it will be
aired at this this summer otherwise
we're gonna proceed at a more leisurely
pace you might say podcast so the
Sadler's lectures podcast I was able to
get quite a few episodes done and
published and out to the general public
so I went through the the five episodes
that we
on Anselm's prosto jian did some stuff
on Heidegger's introduction being in
time and we're in the process of
releasing episodes on friedrich
nietzsche's on truth and lies in an
extra moral sense we're mostly through
that I'll actually be releasing one
later today video work I did manage to
get to book reviews done so I'm moving
on that I didn't get any half-hour hagel
stuff done unfortunately and I wasn't
able to do the self directed study video
but we have videos of each of the events
and I shot a ton of core concept video
footage for my classes that's where my
priority had to be so I released the
last of the videos on an R and released
some videos on Tolstoy is what is art
some videos on Peters singer's
biological basis of ethics essay and
began releasing videos on John Rawls
theory of justice all of which are for
my ethics for artists and designers
course but which some of which I use in
other courses as well and patreon
supporters got to see much of that video
video footage early because that's one
of the perks that they enjoy so you know
if you're interested in that you might
want to consider becoming a supporter
that's what went on in February so what
is coming up in March we've got a lot of
events so I'm gonna run through them
fairly methodically and try not to
comment on any of them until I get to
the end and then I'll tell you a little
bit more about them so here's the the
real tomorrow on February 3rd 6 p.m.
here in Milwaukee at the Mitchell Street
branch of the library we have our
monthly MKE Sophia meeting we're going
to be talking about philosophy and
ethics and sports because it's March
Madness the 11th at 5:00 p.m. online
event so a central time we have our
Hegel Q&A and discussion session you can
video conference with me and ask your
questions about Hegel or about other
things related to German idealism or we
can just kind of shoot the breeze 13th
at 5:00 p.m. we have the second airing
of the new wisdom for life radio show
co-hosted by myself and Dan Hayes talk
more about that in just a minute
then on the 14th 12:00 p.m. we'll have
the AMA asked me anything session make
sure you get there early because
questions pile up and I don't always get
to all of them
later that afternoon for patreon
supporters at a certain level on the
14th 2 p.m. philosophy chant video
conferencing with me ask whatever they
want and I'll engage with the questions
that they they bring up or topics or
whatever they want to discuss on the
26th at 6:00 p.m. here in Milwaukee at
the Shorewood Public Library we have the
MKE stoic fellowship that's a in person
group you're welcome to come and join us
even if you don't know anything about
stoicism I should mention as well it
looks like I skipped over one event and
that is the worlds of speculative
fiction we are going to be looking at
Steven Donaldson on the 12th at 7:00
p.m. and that will be at the Brookfield
Public Library so we're looking at the
Chronicles of Thomas covenant if you've
ever read that epic fantasy cycle which
now has reached 10 books and then
jumping ahead back to the 27th 5 p.m.
next episode of wisdom for life that'll
be our third radio episode and finally
finishing up on the 28th at 12 p.m.
we'll have our video premiere self
directed study in philosophy focusing on
how to study Augustine of Hippo so a lot
of stuff there what do I want to
highlight in that
obviously the wisdom for life radio show
so that is on Riverwest radio which
broadcasts here the Milwaukee area on a
fairly small radius because it's a
community radio station and it
broadcasts live over the internet
everywhere in the world so it's very
easy to find that there's also episodes
are archived on their soundcloud I don't
know if they go to Spotify or anything
like that that's a good question for you
to ask Riverwest radio themselves as
opposed to asking me because they don't
have the answer but you can listen to it
quite easily on your phone you know on
other devices however it is that you you
do that so the whole idea behind the
show which has been a long time in the
making is about helping people
understand philosophy in practical ways
so we're doing the stuff with some rigor
but we're also doing it for a popular
audience and each show we're gonna talk
about at least one philosophical
practice this time we did negative
visualization we'll see what we do next
time and we'll also deal with listener
provided questions about real life
issues not abstract things like you know
is philosophy compatible with theology
but more like am having this problem
what can philosophy say to help me with
that so that's the show
what else do I need to say about things
you know you're always welcome to come
to the public events here in town I
video record many of them but not all of
them and the online events the only
thing to remind you about is the times
are all central time and you can find
all of this either on the reason io
calendar right go to reason io comm or
on my Facebook page I have all the
events listed there as well got a lot of
stuff lined up for this month you know
my usual roster of philosophical
counseling and tutorials picking up a
few new clients here and there
teaching my classes you know developing
content for them doing all the grading
all that that kind of stuff and you know
I'm also doing some consulting work
mostly in the the ethics field but also
in a few other things having to do with
argumentation with businesses podcast so
this month it's going to be a lot of
nicho we did an opinion poll on YouTube
and Twitter and Nietzsche appears to at
least on YouTube which of the most votes
below everybody else out of the water so
after finishing up truth and lies and an
extra moral sense I'm gonna begin
converting my lecture videos on thus
Spoke Zarathustra into podcast episodes
that you can listen to and download then
we're gonna hit on the person who got
number two in the poll and that is
Blaise Pascal some of the episodes or
the videos that I did on his posses I'll
be converting those two to podcast as
well and then if we have time at the end
of the month I'll start working on
Epictetus discourses I've got a lot of
material on that and people often ask
the question so I'm going to address
this right away are the podcast episodes
different than the videos and the answer
is in general no because that's what I'm
taking them from I'm using the core
concept videos but I'm boosting the
sound quality and I'm taking out all of
the arms as you knows as best as I can
so that takes a bit of time but produces
a more listenable thing so instead of
like just clicking on YouTube and
listening from there you can download
the episodes and listen to them you know
on soundcloud or iTunes or Google Play
or Apple music or whatever whatever else
it is that you're doing so that's the
podcast videos of course I'll be
recording videos
the events and that includes some of the
online events I'll be you know the AMA
session you can go back to you can
actually see in the chat what people are
asking as I'm responding to it and if I
I hope I will get to some pop ups as
well I'll think about some good topics
for those and so those videos will be
available as well I'm gonna do more book
reviews this month so I can start
getting myself unburied from the stacks
that are waiting for me half hour hagel
videos I've got some time allotted for
working on those gonna get that self
directed study video going so I can get
that series back on track and I got a
lot of core concept material I need to
either release or shoot so I've got
stuff waiting for you on Rawls John
Stuart Mill's on Liberty but I also need
to shoot so I need to shoot some more
material on John Stuart bills on liberty
as well but I also need to shoot some
stuff on Mary Wollstonecraft's a
vindication of the rights of women on
Nell noddings work on care ethics and
probably if I can get to it
some stuff on various writings of of
Marx because as we're moving into our
ethics classes we're going to be looking
at race class gender issues so I need to
have some some useful videos for for
that and that's that's what I'll be
working on so a lot of stuff going on
here again you know you might want to
tune in to the radio show that's
probably the biggest news of the month
wisdom for life Fridays every other
Friday rather
5:00 to 6:00 p.m. Central Time streaming
here in the Milwaukee area but also
streaming everywhere else and if you
missed the episode you can go back to it
later on and listen to it so hope all of
you have a good month and
I'm gonna hopefully get all this stuff
done that I've got lined up and maybe
I'll see some of you at the online or
face-to-face events
you